PRABHAKAR RAGHAVAN: Hello,
everyone, and again, welcome.
My name is Prabhakar, and I'm
responsible for the Google Apps
products.
The journey I'm going to take
you on today goes back 10 years
when we [INAUDIBLE]
out to the world
what we then called Google
Apps for Your Domain.
This was primarily centered
on our Gmail offering--
our flagship email
offering-- that's
used by over a billion
users today-- active users.
But in time, we added
calendaring, unique cloud-based
real-time collaborative
editing, video conferencing,
and a host of other
suite services
that really rested in one
fundamental principle--
that people work together.
They work better together in
the cloud collaboratively.
And my word, what a
journey it's been.
Today, we're thrilled
to have and honored
to have over two million
customers who depend on us
every day to enable their
employees to be successful.
And as we work with
these customers,
we've learned a
tremendous amount
of what it takes to make
organizations successful.
And with that, we have evolved.
And I couldn't be more excited
to announce today that we
have evolved into G Suite.
G Suite is an integrated
suite of applications designed
to enable workers to
collaborate better
in the cloud with the power of
Google's machine intelligence
to enable them to work smarter.
And my team and I are
really excited to invest
in introducing G Suite to you.
You'll get a lot more about
this in the weeks and months
to come.
But what does this really
mean for our customers
and for our products?
This industry has been fixated
on personal productivity
for three decades now,
and in the process,
a lot of good things
have happened.
We've all created
tools that we use
every single day-- many tools
that we love to use, some
that we love to hate.
But that's the current
plane at which we operate--
personal productivity.
What G Suite aims to
do is to elevate that
beyond to a couple of levels.
First-- and I'll
walk you through this
in the next few
minutes-- we want
to think about teams
as first class objects.
What do teams do
in organizations?
How do they work together?
What journeys do they embark
on in their day-to-day lives?
And then from there,
we'll go on to what
it takes to make
organizations successful.
So again, by thinking about
people-- the atomic units
in an organization.
And I'm going to dwell
for the next few minutes
on a series of
announcements that I'm
really excited about
bringing to you today
on the power of
machine intelligence
enabling people to
be more successful
in your organizations.
A study by McKinsey estimates
that the average employee
really gets about two
productive, creative days
in a week.
So what you ask are they
doing the other three days?
Well, they're searching
for information,
they're scheduling meetings,
they're triaging e-mail.
Things that we think
of as mundane work.
That's where we
think that the power
of artificial
intelligence we can make
things dramatically better.
The first example
I'm going to give you
of something we're launching
now comes from Google Drive.
Many of you are used to file
systems, to file repositories,
and I'm sure you can
identify with this journey
that people go through
over and over again.
You go into your
file repository,
you scratch your head-- I
know it's in there somewhere.
Do I search?
Do I browse?
Do I filter?
Do I try and guess
who gave me that file?
And on a good day, our studies
show that the average employee
spends 15 seconds each time
they come into a file depository
before they get to the
file they're looking for.
And that's only on a good day.
Lots of people don't find
what they're looking for,
and then they go off
and ask their colleagues
and bug a whole bunch of
people across the organization.
So we challenged our engineers
and said, we're Google.
We need to do better than this.
And this is what
they came up with.
Quick Access uses
your activity patterns
to predictively serve
up to you the file
that you're about to need
just as you arrive in Drive.
No searching, no
typing, no clicking.
You come in there--
and I've been
using this feature
for a few weeks now,
and a lot of the
time, we get it right.
And the best part of machine
intelligence and machine
learning is as
the system learns,
it gets better and better.
So that's the first of
the unique announcements
I'm happy to make today.
And Google Drive Quick Access
will give you your files
even before you ask for them.
All right, so you've
got the file you wanted.
What do you want to do with it?
I'm going to walk you through a
series of machine intelligence
capabilities in our
document editors
that we collectively refer
to as Explore capabilities.
The first of these
I'll do as a demo,
and then after
that, I'll walk you
through the other capabilities.
And I'm joined by my
colleague Jeremiah
who's going to put up on
the screen a spreadsheet.
So this is exploring Sheets.
Can we have Jeremiah
on the screen, please.
Great.
So this is a spreadsheet of
somewhat fictitious sales data
from the last holiday season.
And what we can bring
here is the power
of Google's natural
language processing.
The problem we're
trying to solve
is a large fraction of people--
about a third of people
who use Sheets-- have no
idea what formulas are.
They don't want to know.
They want to do some analysis.
They should be able to ask
questions and get the answers.
So Jeremiah is now going to
ask a natural language question
just as an analyst might ask.
So what's the average profit
margin for [? socks. ?]
And if the demigods are with
us, out pops the answer-- 0.45.
And what it did
underneath the covers
was to take that natural
language question
and transcribe it into
a formula that just
got executed against the Sheet.
Let's try another
example Jeremy.
What was the most popular
product on Black Friday?
Fair question, you might ask.
And by comes the answer-- belts.
Again, this is where
we're able to take
the power of natural
language processing,
and Jeremiah, do you
mind showing the formula?
Great.
So right there, he's showing
you the fairly complex formula
that got drawn out
of that fairly not so
complex natural language query.
Excellent.
Thanks, Jeremiah.
If we could have the
main slides back please.
Good.
Well, not quite.
Could we switch back please.
Excellent.
I'm going now to briefly touch
upon the explored functionality
in a couple of other settings
in our document editors.
Explore in Slides attacks
the following problem.
When you're creating
a presentation,
you want to get
your message across.
You want to get your
content in and deliver it.
You don't want to lose more
time formatting and polishing
and rounding the
corners of boxes.
That's not what
you're here to do.
What Explore in Slides does
is you drop in your content,
and in a couple of
clicks, it automatically
formats it into a beautiful
presentation that's
going to have your boss thinking
that you stayed up all night
polishing the slides.
Great.
Very quickly, let me touch
upon Exploring Google Docs.
Four years ago in 2012,
we launched a feature
that we called
Docs Research where
we coupled the Google search
engine into your Docs editor.
And it's somewhat
gratifying to see
the world take notice and start
to do similar things right now,
but we decided to
go much further.
You want to be able to compose
a document about Neil Armstrong,
and it starts to pull in content
about the Apollo 11 mission
from Google's gigantic
knowledge graph.
That is the power
of Exploring Docs.
What we can do is bring
in related concepts
not only from the web,
but also documents
from your drive
and shared content
across your company's
repositories.
Let me turn to my next example.
Calendars and scheduling have
been unchanged for 200 years.
A calendar is a bunch
of boxes in a grid.
And an assistant
is some poor soul
who's hunched over
a terminal who's
moving those boxes around
all day for a living.
This is the 21st century, folks.
That's not acceptable.
So we decided to change that.
Here's how Find Time
works launching today
in Android and iOS,
soon to come to the web.
You know that a bunch of
people have to get together.
We haven't yet
gotten to the point
of guessing who those people
are, but let's say you tell us
who those people are.
We then figure out
automatically looking
at everybody's schedules,
understanding people's meeting
patterns, and finding
the best time for them
to meet to maximize
the probability
the meeting actually happens.
And in time, as
the system learns,
you're going to get
better with things
like find the right
room for them to meet.
So the promise
here is scheduling
should become more and
more automated and less
and less reliant and prone
to human error and trouble.
So as a result of
this, you're going
to start to see more
innovation in the space.
And in time, you shouldn't
have those poor souls
hunched over terminals
dealing with this stuff.
All right, I'm going
to pause for a second
and reflect a little bit on all
of this machine intelligence
capability.
I'm going to begin
with a confession.
I worked in these
technologies for two decades,
and I will confess
that I did not
foresee that a day would
come in my lifetime
when computers would beat
the World Go champion.
I did not foresee that
in a matter of months,
we could take those same
machine learning kernels
and turn it into an engine
that answers 10% of emails
automatically.
So Smart Reply composes
responses to emails,
and 10% of the time, users
are perfectly happy using
what the machine has composed.
I did not foresee that
in this generation,
we'd have machines that
could take images or videos
and annotate them, or real-time
cloud-based translation where
you hold up a phone
to a sign and it gets
translated into your language.
And I attribute
this to the maniacal
focus our founders
Larry and Sergey
put in machine
intelligence and forced us
all to re-examine the
assumptions on which we're
building these products.
Now, there's a second
point I want to make here.
There's a lot of
players out there
talking about artificial
intelligence being the future.
And that's great.
At Google, artificial
intelligence
is not the future, it's
current shipping reality.
And that's why we're able to
move from beating the World Go
champion 40 years
ahead of schedule
to products that use exactly
the same technologies in months.
This is not a lab experiment.
What it takes is a way of
life, a way of transcribing
a business problem into
a metric optimization
that machine learning then
turns into beautiful experiences
like these.
That's what I had to
say about individuals.
Now let's uplift this to the
level of team productivity
because I believe this is
going to become increasingly
important in the years to come.
So the point here is we need to
think of teams as first class
citizens and how
they go about doing
their work every single day.
And today, I'm pleased
to make two announcements
in this realm, both going into
early adopter program today.
The first we call Team Drives.
So what's Team Drives?
Wow, I didn't realize
it would be so popular.
So the idea of Team Drives is
to get away from the notion
that content is
owned and managed
by individuals because at some
level, people join a group.
And when they leave, the
content gets orphaned.
You don't want that.
So Team Drive is a
setting where a team
is a first class object in terms
of its ownership of content.
Teams manage content, assign
content to other people,
and all of this is fully dynamic
as the identity of a team
keeps changing because
people can join a team,
people can exit a team, and
all of that leaves team content
unaffected.
The second announcement
I want to bring you
is a new Hangouts
experience for video.
When you make a phone call,
you don't pick up your phone
and say, is that person
on Verizon or Vodafone?
Do they have an iPhone, Android?
You just dial their number
and you're off to the races.
It's that same fluidity we want
to bring to video conferences.
It should be just as seamless
to make a video conference.
So the new Hangouts
experience, also entering
early adopter program today,
offers the following features.
First, as always with Google,
no downloads, no plug-ins,
nothing extraneous.
Simple link-based
video conferencing.
No identities.
So you can easily communicate
with partners, with customers,
with anybody outside
your domain-- candidates.
Things should be [INAUDIBLE]
every single day.
Moreover, every meeting
by default-- and this
has been one of our
biggest requests
from customers-- by
default, every meeting
has a phone number.
So if you're caught in
the airport security
line at the time of
the video conference--
an experience I'm sure every
one of you can relate to-- you
don't have to find a nice
place where you're visible.
Just pick up the
phone and join in.
As simple as making
a phone call.
Expect to hear more
from us in this area.
But the new Google
Hangouts video experience
is an early adopter
also starting today.
All right, so I've
talked about people.
I've talked to about the next
layer of teams, and as I said,
you should expect to hear more
announcements in this area
from us with other products.
Let's now up-level it to the
success of the organization.
And really, the goal here is
to break down the information
silos in enterprise.
Three months ago, we launched
a unique cloud-based search
and assist capability
that we call Springboard.
What this gives
you is the ability
to harness all of the
content in your enterprise,
whether first party
or third party.
Bring it into a single
index, and first of all,
provide secure
search, search that's
sensitive to reorganizations.
So you have a reorg,
and instantly,
content you're not privy
to is hidden from you.
Or if you become
privy to content,
conversely, you can access
that content through the search
functionality.
So this is technically
pretty challenging,
and I'm thrilled to say my
team has pulled this off.
But there's more.
You're all familiar
with Google Now
on the consumer side in similar
fashion with enterprises.
This capability proactively
provides you assist capability.
So when you're walking
into a meeting,
the assist capability
surfaces a document and says,
here's the document. you're
going to need for that meeting.
And if you look really
carefully at the screenshot,
the document being
suggested here
comes not from Google but
from Box, with whom we just
signed a partnership
to be able to service
exactly this kind of content.
So it doesn't have to
be just Google content.
It's whatever's relevant
to your business.
So that, in summary,
is G Suite--
a suite of applications
designed to make your business
run smarter.